we've gettin this program in Britain
where the two remaining contenders to
become Conservative Party leader and the
next British Prime Minister have faced
off in a televised debate their big
clash coming on their approach to brexit
former foreign minister Boris Johnson is
expected to win the ballot of party
members if he does he'll have just about
three months to take Britain out of the
EU DWS begin' Maas joins us now with
more on this from London good morning
baguette in many ways this debate as we
just heard comes too late doesn't it
with most party members already
apparently having voted well of course
we don't know yet but the assumption is
that they are a punctual Bunch they're
Conservative Party members who are
determining Britain's next prime
minister and that a lot of them would
have already voted that's frustrating
for Jeremy Hunt the Foreign Secretary
who really is the Challenger of Boris
Johnson Boris Johnson
leaked the clear front-runner but
nevertheless aremy hunt tried his best
because this was really his chance to
turn at least ace people's opinions who
have invited and he did land some blows
he made much of Boris Johnson's being
evasive maybe not answering the question
properly I thought it was interesting
though afterwards there were
Conservative Party members giving their
opinion and one woman said well even if
he doesn't answer the question Boris
Johnson she was a Boris Johnson
supporter what she wanted is some sort
of humor
some light touch and I think this is
what a lot of members of the
Conservative Party want they just want
some but he was like a tonic for the
party who they really think can also
lead the country to the next election
victory and many people still think that
this is Boris Johnson and not Jeremy
Hunt okay what what about brexit was it
the main issue last night yes for sure
brexit is really the overarching issue
nothing much gets done on British
politics because there the country is
basically an inner standstill in a
lockdown because the brexit situation is
so
clean it's really not clear what money
there will be for the future for example
so tax cuts are also an issue is
something that Boris Johnson has
promised Jeremy Hunt has questioned
whether this is the right time for it
but really it's breaks it and in this
context it is very interesting to see
that Labour's position has recently
shifted has become clearer in supporting
a second referendum because at this
point we are getting closer to the next
deadline and brexit which is the 31st of
October we really don't know whether the
situation will be resolved until then so
the possibility of an absolute
standstill and possibly the the risk of
Britain crashing out of the European
without any deal becomes bigger by the
day
and as such in this situation labour has
said they want a second referendum and
this is also something that the next
future Prime Minister Jeremy Hunt or
Boris Johnson will have to will have to
decide on whether they would contemplate
it at this point in time they say
clearly no okay now if it is Boris
Johnson
what would a Prime Minister Boris
Johnson do as his first order of
business on brexit well they really
wouldn't have much time to measure out
the apartment and Downing Street and
order the new cartons they really have
to pack their bags and go to Brussels
and Boris Johnson has insinuated that he
is the right man to get a different deal
with Brussels they will try and
renegotiate they have seen the trees
amazed ian has failed time and again and
they have promised that they will get a
better deal now from Brussels we have
had that that is very unlikely that they
will give ground in a big way but
nevertheless it's what both what it
would both candidates have promised and
what they will do but it's really not
much time the 31st of October is the
next deadline and to get meaningful
changes out of Brussels and to get this
through the House of Commons done and
into law it's very very tight indeed
beggared thanks so much for that
from one